[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce Nouveau Journal de la
rédaction de TV Phil 78 nous sommes le
vendredi 13 mars 2015 et aujourd'hui
nous parlerons notamment politique
premier tour des départemental le
weekend prochain comment vote par
procuration le mode d'emploi à suivre
avis aux abonnés de la médiathèque de 50
ans neline de lourd travau travaux vont
débuter il faudra dainavant vous rendre
dans les locaux temporaires aménagés
dans le centre commercial Skywest et
puis ce qu'il faut retenir de la semaine
mobilisation contre la fermeture d'une
école à plaisir ou encore inquiétude de
la Fédération du bâtiment sur le
ralentissement des chantiers la
participation au scrutin départemental
s'annonce relativement faible et
pourtant comme pour chaque élection
aucune excuse pour ne pas s'exprimer il
est possible encore aujourd'hui
d'établir des procurations le mode
d'emploi avec Michel midoro et Mélanie
poet les élections départemental sont
programmés les dimanches 22 et 29 mars
si vous ne pouvez pas vous rendre
physiquement dans votre bureau de vote à
ces dates il existe le vote par
procuration le principe une personne
appelée le mandant désigne un mandataire
qui votera à sa place la procédure a été
simplifié depuis l'année dernière donc
il suffit de se rendre au commissariat
ou à la gendarmerie avec donc une pièce
d'identité et le SERFA donc SERFA qu'on
peut remplir en ligne sur internet ou
directement sur place au commissariat ou
la gendarmerie donc cette personne donc
le mandant donne procuration à une
personne qui est le mandataire et ce
mandataire donc ça peut être n'importe
quelle personne inscrit sur les listes
électorales et domicilié sur la même
commune que le mandant ça peut être
n'importe qui ça peut être un collègue
un voisin un ami à condition que cette
personne qui va voter pour vous soit
inscrit sur les listes électorales une
fois la procédure validée par les
services de la mairie le mandataire peut
officiellement voter le jour du scrutin
la personne le mandataire donc arrive au
bureau de vote avec sa pièce d'identité
sa carte d'électeur donc elle précise
dans le bureau de vote qu'elle va voter
donc pour quelqu'un donc ensuite dans
les bureaux de vote il y a des des
étapes de vérification pour voir qu'on a
bien cette procuration et que les noms
coïncident et ensuite la personne peut
voter euh à la place de de quelqu'un
d'autre au total 5 à 8 % des personnes
inscrites sur les listes électorales
devraient voter par procuration pour les
élections départementales cette année ça
fonctionne très très bien on a
énormément de de procurations que ce
soit donc pour les élections municipal
de 2014 et pour cette année on en a
quand même de plus en plus là si vous
n'avez pas encore fait votre demande de
procuration pas de panique vous pouvez
envoyer les documents jusqu'à la veille
du scrutin toutefois les responsables de
l'état civil recommande de remplir votre
procuration 3 à 5 jours avant pour
pouvoir traiter l'ensemble des
demandes la Fédération française du
bâtiment dans les ivelines qui s'invite
dans cette campagne justement des
élections départementales cinq candidats
de cinq formations politiques
différentes étent présents à Versailles
mercredi matin avec les professionnels
du
secteur lutter contre les offres basses
valoriser l'apprentissage maintenir le
soutien financier voici trois des 10
propositions que la Fédération française
du bâtiment veut mettre en avant avec
l'inquiétude d'une baisse de budget liée
notamment à celle des dotations des
communes entraînant donc la diminution
des marchés la part des investissements
en travaux de bâtiment étit de l'ordre
de 20 % dans le budget précédent
jeaurais pas vous donner le le chiffre
en grandeur donc c'est tout de même
quelque chose d'important et encore une
fois nombre d'entreprises ivelinoises
travaillent pour le Conseil Général pour
l'année 2014 le budget s'levait à 1,2
milliard d'euros dans les ivelines le
bâtiment représente 6800 entreprise dont
3000 sont des artisans moi je travaille
beaucoup sur les églises et bâtiments
anciens pour les municipalités donc et
maintenant nous sommes obligés de
trouver des marchés alors la crise à
bien c'est que le particulier s'est
recentré un peu plus sur son immobilier
ce qui lui permet de faire des travaux
de rénovation quand il le peut selon la
Fédération près de 100000 emplois ont
été perdus depuis 2008 en phase 2 quatre
candidats aux élections départementales
pour répondre aux inquiétudes des
professionnels il y a aussi des
équipements publics qui sont dans les
compétences du Conseil départemental et
donc là il y a aussi à la fois à
construire à rénover à rendre accessible
et cetera et donc c'est avec les
entrepreneurs du bâtiment qu'il faut
travailler moi-même je vois année après
année que notre niveau d'investissement
que nous faisons tout pour maintenir est
quand même sensiblement moins grande
qu'elle ne l'a été donc à partir de là
je suis assez bien placé pour comprendre
que tous les marchés que nous ne passons
pas c'est autant de travail que nous ne
donnons pas aux entreprises nous avons
au Front national beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs nous avons toujours
défendu au Front national la petite
entreprise la défense des PME des PMI
c'est un point essentiel de notre
programme que ça c'est la vitalité d'un
pays conseil général et et un moteur
quand il y a des subventions pour les
communes il y a des travaux faits par
les communes avec l'argent des communes
mais aussi avec une aide du dé
appartement donc quelque part ça fait
des travaux
importants pour les entreprises et la
construction parole de soutien à la
filière constate de la situation mais
pas vraiment de solutions apporté
difficile en effet de faire des
propositions en la matière quand on sait
que la principale compétence du conseil
général ce n'est pas la construction
mais le social et que les
investissements en travaux des
collectivités sont soumis au code des
marchés publics et ne peuvent pas
favoriser des entreprises d'un secteur
géographique la Fédération du Bâtiment
des ivin compte 1200 adhérents et
puisqu'il est question de politique
sachez que dimanche sur Radio sensation
l'hebdo politique recevra Henri paayot
le maire de coignère UMP est désabusé il
a décidé vous le savez de quitter son
poste il a révélé la date officielle de
son départ extrait il y a plus d'éthique
il y a plus de morale il y a plus que
l'intérêt particulier qui compte
l'intérêt général tout le monde s'en
fout aujourd'hui chacun pour soi et bien
moi personnellement je suis désolé je
n'ai pas été édu
et par mes parents et par les jésuites
parce que c'est eux qui m'ont éduqué
euh et je ne suis pas goiste je dirais
pour rien non plus bon donc je ne
supporte pas ce qui se passe et j'ai
estimé au mois de décembre dernier que
je me refusais maintenant à servir de
caution à tout ça pour moi c'est terminé
je démissionnerai très exactement le 10
avril à à minuit pourquoi parce que dans
les 10 minutes qui passéderont je ferai
voter le budget préitif de l'année et et
qui va vous succéder alors en tout cas
qui vous souhaitez voir vous succéder
bah c'est extrêmement simple j'ai une
équipe qui s'appelle qu démocratie dans
lequel il y a 22 personnes plus ceux qui
n'ont pas été élus qui sont sur la liste
d'attente mais qui participent au débat
donc ce sera comme au Vatican je vais
les convoquer en mérit quoi dire je vais
fermer les portes à clés et puis je
leuri dit bah écoutez on ne sortira de
là que lorsqu'il y aura quelqu'un pour
me
remplacer mercredi est sorti en salle
Selma long métrage qui retrace la lutte
historique du docteur matin Martin
Luther King pour garantir le droit de
vote à tous les citoyens et qui a
conduit le président Johnson à signé la
loi sur le droit de vote en 1965 une
sortie qui touche particulièrement les
étudiants de première année de licence
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin baptisé promotion Martin
Luther King qui travaille autour du
discours célèbre qui débute par ses mots
i have a dream l'Institut d'études
culturelles et international leur
propose en effet d'ici au 16 mars de
rédiger leur propre texte Virginie
augustiniac professeur agrégé à
l'Université de versaill 50 ans Eveline
était en plateau cette semaine elle est
membre du jury elle nous parlait donc de
ce rendez-vous et du travail qu'elle
mène avec ses étudiants et ça encore un
sens aujourd'hui justement de de parler
tout ça il y a eu beaucoup d'évolution
autour des droits civics aux États-Unis
on peut citer l'élection d'Obama ça
réélection en suite mais ça a pas changé
forcément toute la situation aux
États-Unis voilà ouais non au contraire
je pense que bon il y a une espèce de Al
j'étais surprise d'ailleurs un gros
découragement deette de cette génération
et donc il sont très très p
et donc effectivement la personnalité de
Martin Luther King
reste pH pour pour ces générations là ça
reste quelque chose
d'actualité pas
[Musique]
terminé également invité en plateau
cette semaine christophe Robert il est
le délégué général de la Fondation Abbé
Pierre avec lui nous avons évoqué le
droit au logement opposable la loi
d'Allo un système qui fonctionne mal en
île-defance les demandes Sass écoutez un
extrait de cet entretien qu'est-ce qui
bloque aujourd'hui en île-de-fance alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait pour débloquer
la situation aussi alors tout dépend de
quoi on parle c'estàdire que les outils
aujourd'hui mis à disposition de
l'application de cette loi peuvent être
davantage mobilisé c'est par exemple le
contingent préfectoral de l'État vous
savez en fait l'État a des droits de
réservation qui sont liés à ces
financements de la construction de
logements sociaux Action Logement qui
est l'ancien 1 % logement également et
là il y a encore une bonne partie de
logement qui pourrait être mobilisé pour
répondre aux besoins de ses concitoyens
donc là c'est une action forteier de
l'État qui doit dire ben c'est vraiment
une injonction forte c'està-dire que
c'est l'application de la loi personne
ne doit pouvoir s'en dédouiner il faut
donc mobiliser mais plus largement ça
soulève bien sûr des questions majeures
de politique publique dans leur ensemble
en matière de logement éducation à
présent l'annonce de la fermeture d'une
école maternelle à plaisir qui mobilise
les parents d'élèves une partie d'entre
eux étent mobilisé le weekend dernier
face à la mer Joséphine colmans berger
adjo à l'éducation des échanges
particulièrement tendus alors que la
municipalité envisage de répartir les 44
écoliers inscrits cette année dans de
autres établissements de la ville pour
les parents d'élèves cela signifie tout
simplement à l'avenir des classes
surchargé l'école Camille cludel depuis
plusieurs années maintenant sert quand
même de soupap on va dire aux autres
écoles c'està-dire que quand on arrive à
un chiffre assez élevé d'effectif dans
les autres écoles les enfants viennent
ici sont basculés ici donc parce que ce
qu'on sait c'est que là pour l'instant
on est au mois de mars les effectifs
sont prévus un certain chiffre ils vont
encore évoluer d'ici le mois de juin et
même en septembre donc si en septembre
les classes sont pleines à Jacques
Prévert et à Gérard Philippe les autres
enfants on les met où on les met AC amis
Claudel pour l'instant mais si l'école
ferme il y aura plus de soupap et les
enfants ils vont aller où ils vont
continuer de faire grimper les chiffres
dans les classes rien n'est encore
arrêté les discussions qui se
poursuivent avec l'Éducation nationale
pour terminer ce journal un détour à
présent par la Médiathèque du canal qui
va fermer ses portes pendant 1 an la
structure va être déplacée au centre
commercial Sky West à Montini à partir
du 1er avril pour la durée des travaux
reportage de Michel midero et de yston
berger la médiathèque du canal va
s'offrir un lifting ouvert depuis
1993 le bâtiment situé à montinilo
brotonu va fermé ses portes ce samedi 14
mars pour une durée d'un an objectif
moderniser les 2700 m² de la structure
l'idée étant d'avoir des espaces plus
plus conviviaux avec plus de de place
assis soit de travail soit soit de
détente également des salles d'activités
supplémentaires pour proposer plus
d'offres d'animation et puis va se
moderniser également sur tout ce qui est
offre numérique à partir du mercredi 1er
avril la médiiathèque va être déplacée à
une cinquantaine de mètres les documents
seront installés provisoirement au 2uxè
étage du centre commercial Skywest à
Montini la médiathèque sera rebaptisé
pour l'occasion le petit canal à la
médiathèque le petit canal ça sera 30000
documents donc on va faire un
prélèvement dans l'ensemble de nos
rayons pour avoir un échantillonnage de
collection à offrir pendant une année au
public qui fréquente la médiathèque pour
les habitués de la médiathèque du canal
cette rénovation est plutôt positive moi
je regrette un petit peu mais bon
puisque il paraît qu'on a un endroit on
va pouvoir
récupérer ce qu'on trouvait et peut-être
qu'au retour ça sera mieux quoi si c'est
une histoire de
rénovation tant mieux si c'est pour le
revoir en meilleur ou en plus grand j
que pendant 2 semaines il faudra
chercher peut-être ces documents
ailleurs par exemple je pense au 7 Mar
tout ça utiliser les les services de
réservation pour suivre l'évolution des
travaux de la médiathèque du canal des
vidéos seront mises en ligne tous les
mois sur le site de
l'éiathèque merci de votre fidélité on
se retrouve lundi pour un nouveau
journal complet le point sur l'actualité
locale je vous souhaite un très bon
weekend
[Musique]